cab Andy cook to me this welcome the way
to bake with Kevin Andy the show that
takes you in the kitchen and gives you a
handy I'm Kevin and I'm Andy and we're
going to show you how to make some food
what are we doing today whether we're
cooking it well today we're going to do
media meet us which is a Spanish for mix
it's a traditional Mexican breakfast do
you remember the biggest theme from Star
Wars that discussed or was saying
[Music]
cooking chicken chicken again next to
you that was me good oh really it was
kind of like that you could eat me gosh
while listening to me go and take it
back old school
well this is caught me guess because it
gives me that I think better well I put
anything in my body a I want to know its
name B I want to know what's in it so
what are we going to eat here to that
three tablespoons of olive oil 1/4 cup
of onion chopped quarter cup of red bell
peppers a half of a cake out verita
three cups of thick corn tortilla chips
I know we we do some eggs salsa some
pico de Gaia salt and pepper 1/2 a cup
of Mexican cheese so take your 3 3
tablespoons of olive oil put that pan
we're ready to get going with your other
ingredients we'll pour all those yeah
you're like look at a snake [ __ ] like
in Harry Potter because we're always
doing issue breakfast ticket put it
online dump it in and you can even use
your scraper or your hands to get the
rest of it I don't want that on so I
might use a scraper so we'll let that
let that Brown a little bit oh man it
smells like over the boardwalk in New
Jersey and what might ID pepper I got
bored well goes public peppers onions
and used condoms well at Miss Brown I
will get the eggs I'll start beating egg
what do we do if like done well they
start to brown pretty well start heating
up the yeah when you say Brown said that
just judgment call
is very like a chart that we should go
by color chart or is it just that's
brown enough well they will be smoking
we're kind of like the Kevin Smith way
like there's a right way to do it to
Kevin Smith flavors like this trick so
you want to put a little salt in ahead
of time why because the yolk sac needs
to break down and south
Noatak breakdown absolutely your bedroom
talking here comes my yolk sac
she's like you and you stop talking
about it that way call it little antics
all right so love these again be licking
that let's cut around it up you see this
see the garlic is browning
yeah so let's dump in the salsa verde
with you and whenever for salsa green
green salsa green sauce green sauce
salsa the install yes learn it so again
I smell gases
we're learning basic Spanish which I
should have learned in high school well
yes and live in Los Angeles I took four
years of it man and all I could remember
the donde la patate sorry what am I
doing this for this we're going to pour
that in it's great fat the eggs go in
now and while I can we're going to stick
the burrito and make the burrito and
you're going to kind of try to poop this
out of its thing kind of squeeze it in
there you little baby burn action
[Music]
all right so just the gut just the guts
we're not going to use the tortilla or
any of the chips what do we do this
total bowl yeah because you're leaving
your dirty later
I can't beYOU for you can Kevin I've
made eggs before man I gotta tell you so
you ever thrown all this other [ __ ] net
so we're going to throw our chips in
there now this is also traditionally for
Mexican breakfast big you mind if I do
the dumping you're the master there's
too many chips okay we can add a little
pepper
take a pinch do your attention what's
going to mix with pepper for you this
way yeah that's and then we're going to
cover it actually you sprinkle the
cheese on top so kind of push it all
together and we'll sprinkle on the
cheese cover it and let it melt really
really yeah looking good flat married
Gitmo flattening so that the cheese gets
all over the cheese thing off cuz even
let the cheese melt that's what's good
yeah cover it up put it over their house
and then we wait for it to melt all
right look at that so you kind of chop
it up chop it in half and you know which
after you would whichever happy you
don't what so as you get these on the
plate we have some things that we can
garnish with okay you have some sour
cream and this is cilantro all right
here we go
testing the food that we ourselves made
no longer subject to the tyranny of
other [ __ ] cooks and chefs on we
control the food now here we go
[Music]
[Applause]
pretty good I'm not even it's also
divers please go okay who made this well
done sir
I'd [ __ ] whoever made this I would not
not the aim of every chef music be the
food of love and below the cook or
something like that and that how that
saying goes now I think that about music
thanks for hanging out with us here in
the loop great kitchen at Luke Craig
calm if you want to see us cook some
other specific things go to your social
media your Twitter's your Facebook your
Instagram hashtag Luke crate and say cab
and ego to me this box and we will do it
right here on camera it's just like that
you think do it we will cook that 2x4 we
can bake with Kevin Andy I'm Jeff and
I'm Andy Bon Appetit and I reach over
and it was good
[Music]
you